hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played by me uh today
uh after I had some breakfast usually I
like to start the day you know buy some
breakfast I take metal for a walk or I
do some exercise I play some Blitz some
bullet and then uh well you are ready
for pretty much everything life throws
at you and this game uh is uh not a
great game we've both made some mistakes
in my opponent and my my opponent is a
gentleman named hanzo19 and I I have no
further information on him so that's why
uh the the hoodie guy is there as my
opponent and uh to honor him I am
wearing a hoodie myself as you guys
should do the same uh but yeah let's
let's check out the game it's uh it's
not a perfect game but it has a very
nice finish I'm sure you guys will enjoy
it uh so let's dive straight into it I
had the white pieces and I opened with
Ponte E4 as I usually do I'm an E4
player myself with Ponte five by my
opponent I play Knight F3 Knight to C6
and not Bishop the C4 by me sorry about
that
now here black usually will go for
something like Knight to F6 or Pawn to
C5 if black plays Knight to F6 we go for
Knight G5 that's always very enjoyable
and of course if our opponent goes for
Bishop C5 then we go for the Evans
Gambit but my opponent here uh did not
go Knight F6 or Bishop to C5 he played
Knight to D4 this is a very very old
trap the Blackburn chilling Gambit or
the the costage Gambit and uh it's very
easy to lose the game here I I like to
to play this is black myself and you can
win some very easy games if you don't
know what black is doing Blake black is
offering a Pawn on E5 but if you capture
this spawn then after Queen G5 you will
have a a pretty pretty terrible game the
G2 Pawn is hanging the Knight is hanging
and if you continue with Knight captures
on F7 sort of going after the Rook then
look at this queen captures and G2
attacks The Rook Rook F1 now Queen
characters on e4 with check Bishop
blocks and not Knight to F3 and
smothered mate so this is uh basically
what my opponent wants but I was not
interested in interested in that as I
know what's happening here I just played
Pawn to C3 and interestingly I I
remember last time I checked was uh
probably uh in a book somewhere pretty
sure that C3 was the move that was
recommended against Knight to D4 but the
engine really is not impressed the
engine just says you should capture on
D4 and after he captures you should just
Castle uh leaving Blackwood I would have
doubled deep on and you already have a
nicely developed Bishop so that's uh
what you should go for but okay some
somehow I remember that C3 is the
refutation of this Knight to the D4 idea
and this is what I played so Knight
captures an F3 and queen captures on F3
I'm already threatening Checkmate on F7
we have Queen to F6 by my opponent uh
now defending against Checkmate and I go
back Queen to E2 I don't want to trade
queens and his Queen is on a weird
Square so I'm gonna try and take
advantage of that as sometimes in the
future he played Ponte D6 I castled uh I
could also play D4 or something like
that but I like my Bishop here I want to
play F4 captures and I want to take
advantage of that um well soon to be
open f file he played Bishop to E6
attacks my Bishop here and I played
Bishop to B5 check and this is already
not a great move by me here I should
just uh capture
um the bishop and after Queen captures I
should pick up the pawn on B7 that's how
you should play this but this is a three
minute Blitz game and I'm not really a
pawn person I just go Bishop to B5 check
Ponta C6 and the bishop to A4 uh we have
Queen back to d8 now freeing up the F6
where for the Knight and now I strike in
the center with D4 E Capture Sunday for
C captures and Bishop to E7 continuing
development and not Knight the C3 I do
the same Knight to F6 and now I strike
with Knight with Pawn to F4 I want to
play F5 and make this light core version
a bit weird on E6 he castles King side
and now I play Pawn to F5 we have Bishop
to D7 and now Bishop to E3 Bishop D3 not
probably not the most useful move but I
wanted to play Bishop to E3 and Rook 8
to D1 before I start pushing uh he
played B6 and now I played Rook 8 D1 uh
also you you could just start with Ponte
E5 Pawn to E5 is just beautiful here for
example captures captures and the Knight
really doesn't have a good square if you
play Knight here just Rook 8 to D1 and
white is uh White has a spectacular
position white is winning this by force
but I thought let's play Rook a to D1
before I start pushing the pawns I
played Rook 8 to D1 and but he just
played Queen to C7 so this kind of stops
E5 as now the queen and the pawn cover
D5 square but okay I played Bishop to F4
now preparing E5 and he played C5 which
is uh more often than not a very good
idea I counter in the center with Pawn
to E5 and now he brings the Knight back
to E8 I play Bishop back to C2 I want my
Bishop here controlling this diagonal
for when I bring the queen to H5 to go
for some checkmating ideas he played C
captures on D4 and now I first play
Knight to D5 I attack his Queen and put
pressure on the bishop so he has to play
Queen to d8 to defend the bishop this is
what he did he played Queen to d8 and
now I played Queen to H5 again I should
play F6 here and probably uh or open a
black skiing side a bit sooner and open
up this diagonal but I played Queen to
H5 first leaving this always as an um as
an idea because now F6 would be much
more potent so of course he has to react
to this and he plays Ponta F6 but now I
take advantage of this and I uh use the
diagonal that was just created he played
F6 okay I can't play F6 myself to open
up this diagonal but now I get to use
this diagonal so I played Bishop to B3
uh now threatening all sorts of nasty
discoveries I can move the Knight and
pick up whatever I want so he played
King to h8 and now I was already very
sure that I was going to win this game
easily I played Rook to D3 and now there
isn't all that much you can do here
whatever he does uh he just loses the
game but luckily my opponent played the
D captures on E5 he created a beautiful
Pawn chain here and if I don't have
anything then he should be just better
but luckily I have a forced win here so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this winning idea while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting the first
Checkmate in three and for those of you
who just want to enjoy it is Queen
captures on H7 this is what I played and
now of course there is nothing more to
be done here my opponent did not resign
he wanted to uh he wanted to allow me to
actually get the Checkmate on the board
so he captured the queen king captures
on H7 now I play Rook to H3 with check
of course the king cannot go to G6 so he
went backing to G8 is the only move and
now I can choose between Knight captures
and E7 and Knight captures on F6 I play
Knight captures on F6 and this is now a
double check from the bishop and the
Knight and of course the King has
nowhere to go so this is now a beautiful
uh discovered Checkmate and now if
you're wondering why I captured the pawn
and not the bishop I don't know I just
think it's uh it's uh it's way nicer if
you're you're if your opponent has more
material by the time you ended the game
uh sort of makes the game uh feel more
classy like you yeah I you sacrifice
more material or you didn't go for too
much material but either way I was very
happy with with how the game ended now
yeah I also learned a couple of very
very cool things like Knight to D4
although I know this I always thought
that that C3 was the clear uh refutation
of the knights the D4 liner I don't know
why I just remembered it that way uh
obviously it's not if you play this like
in 2022 the engine just gives this as
much much better for for white so you
should probably play that uh but you
know you might not get that sacrifice
your queen like this if you play all the
old the absolute best moves so you know
it's a it's a give or take uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh I don't show my games very often but
I really really enjoyed this one so I
thought you guys might enjoy that enjoy
it as well and it's a very very cool
line that you might encounter if you
play uh you know if you play E4 if you
play the Italian you you might encounter
this line in Blitz especially in three
minute Blitz Games for maybe bullet or
hyper bullet so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and maybe uh
learned something from this uh well
while while the uh
game I would like to thank Richard
Schwartz Jonathan Bradley Christopher
Norris Microsoft and Michael arboy for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and uh whatever you guys suggest
and think I should I should check out so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day